while i moved from texas to here yeah
you you so you went into california to
texas than to here yeah you remember how
hard i was fighting to stay in texas
remember what you had to listen to walk
me through those list of issues he was
in love with addison adam used to live
in this community called addison and he
was just
yeah he was jason jason yard house jason
from yard house but born and raised in
miami i did not want to come back this
is a very good question though because
there this argument of texas to here is
a different story
so to me
texas on a golf score is probably
the best place to live on a golf score
raising kids
career
job
travel
airport taxes regulation balance left
alone mixture you got every national
possibility cost of living
in every way it's again i would
specifically put dallas at the top and i
would probably put you know dallas
houston austin picking shoes okay san
antonio barclay's not a fan of san
antonio for different reasons but we're
not going to get back today the
basketball player
san antonio women are pretty yeah it's
easy
that's crazy so but you got all these
markets that you're looking at so for us
it got to a point where we kept coming
to florida
for uh a breakers hotel which i love
breakers hotel we've got if you've
stayed there before or not it's
beautiful i spent all day yesterday at
palm beach beautiful i love breakers i
love palm beach and then we started one
day accidentally we're sitting outside
i'm having a cigar and it's like
midnight jen and i are having a glass of
wine right outside of breakers and i
said babe
um
this reminds me of bandar palavi in iran
when my grandparents had a place there
and it was by the water was humid it was
bipolar weather one minute it's raining
next minute it's so emotionally i got
connected i love the water i'm a water
guy
and lifestyle wise i love the lifestyle
here and i said for 20 years i've been
going 80 hours a week i want to still go
80 hours a week but i want to do 80
hours a week by the water yeah and so we
kept everything there and we moved the
media company here because i felt it'd
be a lot easier recruiting talent from
new york or dc or baltimore
to south florida than it would be to
recruit people to dallas i don't think
we can build a media company out of
dallas based on the people that we
wanted to recruit so that's how the
decision making you know it's very
instructive the decision making that
you've been going through because i just
came back from
austin
where i i gave two talks at ut austin
and they might be interested in in
extending an offer and then i met the
people from university of austin i don't
know if have you guys heard of that new
university barry weiss's university very
well i i don't know if that's the right
name but yeah she's involved with it so
it's a new university that's uh trying
to sort of position itself as a
classical liberal school anti-woke you
know critical thinking
and so i met the president of that
university and so my wife and i are
exactly facing that decision if we
decide to eventually leave montreal as
texas better or as florida but i guess
your final consulting advice would be
come to florida well
here's here's uh the other part with
florida versus uh
texas
uh the left has really targeted texas
the last 20 years yeah they've moved
people to texas to convert texas and
they're winning turn it from red to
purple to blue you got it right right
now texas is probably
it used to be florida being a purple
state right now it's probably more texas
being a purple state right okay if it
isn't already there it's on its way to
being there
uh uh florida just flipped red they got
two more uh on the right so now it's
more of a red state than a purple state
adam doesn't like that but it is now a
red state
uh uh florida the governor is young so
if your run rate is you assume this
guy's going to run some say he's going
to run i don't think he's going to run
against trump i don't think it's a good
idea but let's just say he runs
if he runs you know would one of his
guys replace and take florida as a
governor who knows if he stays for six
years
and he's done a good job the state's
probably gonna want another guy like him
to run so let's say that protects you
for another 10 years right so the next
time a leftist type of a person takes
office to be a governor is probably
going to be
10 years from now which is 2032. between
now and 2032 you have enough run rate to
do whatever you want to do and build up
for yourself so
uh i think life's and i think austin i
don't know if you've been to austin with
the homelessness yeah it's not a good
situation when it comes down to the
homelessness
and austin's probably also the most
wokest city in all of texas yeah i know
a lot of people love austin i know musk
is there in a row you know a lot of
people are there but i think uh i think
austin's gonna be the
uh uh stepping stone to end up in
florida i think it's like a pit stop for
a lot of people i think it's gonna be
two three four five years and the next
thing you know people gonna say well i
think i'm moving to florida so you don't
regret your decision let me tell you why
else because
what what is a very big influence on
where you live is a community that
gravitates to a place like armenians
move to glendale california right okay
so guess where we moved to glendale
california assyrians are in turlock if
you live in turlock modesto you know a
lot of assyrians if you're in uh detroit
there's a lot of assyrians you can say
where the irish move to you can say
where italians live you know new york
certain parts where dominicans live
where mexicans live salvadorians live
puerto ricans live
uh
the the young i look at the youngest
movement that's taking place that are
for the most part independent thinkers
that think for themselves and they can
reason that's the crypto community the
crypto community are filled with they
think for themselves okay this doesn't
mean they're left or right but they will
think for themselves right they don't
like control they don't like authority
they don't like people tell them what to
do they want to be left alone they don't
know they don't like centralized they
want decentralized that's the mindset of
somebody that can think for themselves
right the crypto capital of the world is
becoming miami if the crypto capital of
the world is becoming miami those types
of thinkers
are moving to miami okay so then if you
think about you wanting to move to south
florida then you have to go based on age
the younger you are the more south you
are if you want to be around people that
are older the more north you are so if
you want to if you're in your 70s and 80
move to vero beach if you're in your 40s
fort lauderdale's good if you're in your
40s acting like you're in your 20s you
may want to live in miami
like that guys
i don't know
guys so that's that's the processing
when it comes down to
thank you for that
and your tan which is on point right
like i may add you're gonna like that a
lot better here in south florida than in
canada my wife looked at me she goes how
the hell do you get so dark so quickly
literally we just we're just walking
around you're like a middle eastern
hello what are you talking about exactly
right exactly right you have the same
problem you have but if you but if you
talk to nikki freed
nikki fried would say a lot of people in
florida are not happy with florida
did you see what happened
she's running for governor of florida oh
yeah okay she was she was she was kind
enough to come and be on the podcast
last saturday not last saturday this
saturday or last session like eight days
ago or something like that and then we
had jedediah billa here which jedidiah
just launched her show jedidiah billa
live she didn't end up she's now doing
her show three times a week she's from
fox right she's from fox and she was on
the view oh right now she's here with us
she just moved here a couple months ago
and we're hosting her podcast and she's
crushing it she's absolutely she's an
absolute beast you're gonna see that
that the show blow up with what she's
got going on
her and nikki had a exchange if you've
not seen it you have to see it by the
way do we put the exchange of them two
on youtube for
just to put jedediah bela versus nicki
freed have we put that together or not
there's a few of them okay yeah because
i thought that exchange was so powerful
them going back and forth so by the way
i nikki freed some of her policy
positions and her talking points i don't
exactly agree with but i gotta give her
kudos for coming on holding her own she
she's welcome here anytime she wants to
come back she's welcome here anytime so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]